hey everybody welcome back to the
Japanese garden the planet coaster
project with no coasters and pretty much
no buildings either but today I won't be
working on just terraforming and foliage
though today I'll be adding some bridges
into the garden and creating some new
landscapes
so it's something slightly different
from last time so without further ado
let's get into the time-lapse all right
now the first few bridges that I'll be
making are these really small ones along
the side of this path here there are
just two bridges but they're also the
same bridge just copied over twice so
it's not really something that I would
call two different bridges in total I'll
be working on three bridges throughout
the garden in this episode and along
with that doing all of the foliage and
finishing up the terraforming and work
work and everything in this part of the
garden now the general idea behind this
episode as a whole is that a lot of
Japanese gardens tend to recreate some
main scenes in Japanese landscapes so a
lot of gardens tend to create Mount Fuji
only in a very small scale or at least
make a hill that's very similar to and
named after Mount Fuji or they'll be
making a tea house that looks very much
like a very famous tea house somewhere
else in the country or even a set of
stairs up a hill that is modeled after a
different set of stairs somewhere else
so it's a lot of taking Japanese
monuments and scattering them throughout
gardens to sort of recreates miniature
scenes a very famous parts of Japan and
it basically took this idea as a reason
to just copy over things from Japan and
put them into the garden so I wouldn't
have to come up with just my whole own
design for these bridges but instead
just make these bridges based on
existing Japanese designs which for one
you know it makes it a bit more accurate
since I wouldn't really know how to come
up with a bridge design that is actually
fittingly Japanese but not one that
doesn't already exist but at the same
time it's just a free free way to just
copy over things that already exist
which normally I try to do this as few
as possible I try to never copy
something over just gather some general
information and inspiration from the
theme that I'm trying to do and just
trying to work out something completely
unique based on that but in this case
I'm just recreating existing objects and
scenes and in this case the bridge that
are making here and the environment
around it is based on SWE's ng garden in
Kumamoto and I have to be very honest I
don't really know Kumamoto from very
much I just know they have a very famous
castle they have this garden and they're
super famous for their mascot which is
absolutely one of the cutest mascots
probably the cutest mascot for a
Prefecture ever it's pretty much also
what it's generally known for apparently
but it's a it's the garden that I have
is really sweet I would actually love to
go there one day I probably won't
because it's it's very far away and it's
it's difficult to get there but they
have a beautiful castle beautiful city
and its overall just one of those places
in Japan which isn't as touristy as say
places like Tokyo and Kyoto but still
seems like something that's worth a
visit and if you've already seen these
things anyway I'm only in this part
after this garden called series ng which
has this section with these bridges and
this path leading over them and
connecting these little islands which
other than that is just a very typical
Japanese gone and seen some rock work
scattered throughout these bridges and
some simple foliage around them some of
these many accured bushes and some
Japanese pine trees so it's a sort of
typical scene but I thought it would
work quite well over here especially
given that I have this large lake and
this garden in Kumamoto also features a
lake like this what I even took as
inspiration for this but with what I'll
probably change later on is that in the
distance on the other side of the lake
there is Mount Fuji and Suzanne G garden
also has
a super similar setup where you see
Mount Fuji at the end of the lake as you
cross these bridges but it's something
that I probably won't be recreating in
this con and since I think there is a
little bit more than I can do with that
mountain rather than just leaving it
completely empty because in this garden
in Kumamoto the Mount Fuji miniature
recreation Hill is completely devoid of
any foliage it's just grass and I think
it'd be more interesting to actually add
some trees on it to have a path go to
the top of the hill and do something on
top of the hill that you can actually
use it as a way to look over the rest of
the garden which I'll probably get back
to later when actually do that that's
just a future plan and not something
that I've built so far but it's just
something I want to keep in the back of
my head is one of the plans for making
the rest of this garden now over here I
experiments it a little bit with making
a wooden coastline just by putting some
wooden posts on the side and holding
back the lamp like that it's something
what you do see in some gardens there's
a there's multiple ways in which you can
make that border between the water and
land you can just have nothing or you
can have some beaches or you can have
some rock work or you can have like
stone or concrete walls but I also think
it's quite interesting to mess around
with the idea of just placing wooden
walls in there but it's not something
that I'll think I'll do more in the rest
of this garden I think I like the look
of the rock work along the side of the
water a little bit more anyway that's
just about it for that little scene so
really in the sort of sense of a
Japanese gone and you've got these
different scenes throughout the
landscape and in each of them you've
sort of gotten a different area to
picture and in this case I wanted to
move to another area and work on
something else and in this part I'll be
recreating more or less recreating the
general atmosphere of a place called
Nikko which is north of Tokyo it's quite
far away from Tokyo but it's quite
famous for featuring some really old
really beautiful and super detailed
shrines and temple
and it also has this bridge which is
quite famous Oh apparently I'm not gonna
work on that quite yet
well never mind I completely lost track
of what I was doing in my time house
we'll get back to that later but for now
I'm working on this very quick stone
bridge which isn't actually gonna be all
that much I'll be I'll be back to unique
or very quickly but over here I wanted
to have this stone bridge which is based
on a bridge in kou shibasaki garden in
Tokyo which is the one place that have
actually been here and it's just a
simple stone platform leading across the
lake with in the middle of that platform
kind of toward the side and opening with
a small rounded stone bridge
so that there's actually a part where
the water can actually pass through it's
a very simple bridge but it's something
in which I wanted to try and give him
the future sight lines of the garden I
think it'll look pretty neat also yeah
I'm trying to make my stone bridges out
of wood it's something which I did with
the earlier bridge as well there just
isn't anything that's made out of stone
in planet coaster that's small enough to
really create these round bridge
features especially not the small posts
so I just have to opt for making wooden
posts look kind of like stone by going
for a similar color but it's it's still
not exactly perfect I just hope that
with the context of all the textures
around it
being out of actual stone and looking
very much like stone that the wooden
posts can at least look stone ish enough
to pass for a stone bridge basically now
back to the thing that I was originally
gonna work on I wanted to create two
ways to get to the other side mainly
because in-game it's not possible to
make your guests actually walk over
these rocks but I thought for one it
would be interesting to have this rocky
way of passing the river it's something
that you see quite often in Japanese
gardens whether it would just be a rocky
path alongside a lake or a rocky path to
actually cross a small River it's always
something that you know you see your
nature and it's quite neat to recreate
so I thought I would do that
but eventually since this is planet
coaster I will need some actual paths to
get people to the other side but that's
just about something that I'm gonna do
anyway as well since I'm gonna build a
bridge on the top of this little valley
over here now the valley isn't exactly a
river but I wanted to make it look kind
of similar you've got these little
miniature mountains in the back with
this little valley between them so Tudor
recreates the idea of having a small
stream that comes down from the
mountains and has a bridge right at the
top over there
trying to use a bit of force perspective
by placing small bushes and trees at the
forefront to make this actually look
like a proper valley and like you're
actually going up the mountains whereas
the actual height difference for the
past is just about like 3 or 4 meters
it's really all quite small so I'm gonna
use the or I'm gonna have to use the
foliage to my advantage to make this all
look larger than it really is and to
create the illusion of having more of a
mountain like landscape even though it's
all very low but yeah that's really the
idea sort of stream coming down from the
mountains with this bridge at the top of
it and I mentioned Niko earlier because
the bridge is gonna be modeled after the
incorporate I know I almost just said
something really bad it's gonna be
modeled after this the shinkuro bridge
in Niko you could tell how horrible my
Japanese is even after half a year of
being here and having Japanese classes
every week days it's crazy I'm sorry
Japanese people I'm horrible anyway so
it's it's it's modeled after the
shinkuro bridge in Nikko and it's just
one of the most beautiful bridges in
Japan generally seen as that at least I
unfortunately haven't been there really
wish that I did but right now I don't
really quite have the time for it I'm
sort of prioritizing theme park visits
over it but it's a really beautiful
bridge anyway used to be parts of a
shrine I believe over there and was only
open to the public a few decades ago but
by now it's one of the like major
tourist destinations over there and
there's lots of beautiful pictures on
this on the internet it's
really beautiful Ridge and I basically
wanted to recreate it because it's one
of these more typical japanese-style
bridges that you'll see in a lot of
movies or Japanese inspired cultural
items where the bridge is like rounded
and has a red fence with all this
detailing on it that's the sort of
bridge that this is whereas the earlier
stone bridges that I've made so far are
really just much more simple designs so
yeah this will also more or less be one
of the signature viewpoints or I guess
you could even say weenies of this
garden plus I just wanted to make this
because it seemed like a fun experiment
I've always wanted to try making a
bridge like this but I've never quite
done it I've done a few similar ideas in
fantasy valley god that's a long time
ago but it was never quite the way that
I liked it especially since the pieces
were pretty limited back then and now we
can actually recolor everything to get
the colors that we are looking for so
yeah this is slightly different from
what I've done so far and definitely one
of the things in the garden which I am
the most happy with I'm quite happy with
how it turned out in the end even if
it's still pretty simple I think it
convincingly looks like a Japanese
bridge and it's quite similar to the
shinkuro bridge even if it's not exactly
the same it's much more it's much
smaller it has slightly different
details but I think the general feeling
is very similar so now into the rock
work and the foliage to make this look
like it's an actual mountain valley I
decided to have some more mud and stuff
like that these different textures at
the bottom of the valley to make it
actually kind of looked like a small
stream running down the hill I chose not
to have an actual waterfall down there
since I thought
for now that might not be very necessary
and just look weird and I think I prefer
the try look but maybe I'll change that
in the future I'm definitely open to any
kind of suggestions or ideas but for now
I think especially given that in planet
coaster if you have this lights coming
from the opposite side and this whole
valley is gonna be in the shadow the
water textures I think of the water
fountains that you can use to make that
sort of stream coming down the hill are
just gonna look a little bit weird I
honestly had the same feeling about the
volcano in qawalli Beach and I still
regrets adding waterfalls to that thing
because the textures don't quite work
out well especially in the shadow so for
now just to make everything look a bit
more realistic I was just gonna keep it
try and just focus on the foliage and
the rock work to make this look like a
mountain landscape now as for the
foliage this was one of the most
difficult things to actually make it
work
since the pots were really close to the
valley and I wasn't really planning on
making them that close but there's
nothing there's no other direction that
I can really make the parts in since I
decided to draw a border of this garden
before I started working on the garden
and so I really don't have more space to
work around with here which is kind of
good because it forces you to get into
the small spaces and trying to use the
space as much as you can which in a real
life Japanese gone and they should have
done as well since these gardens are
quite small and definitely much more
smaller than they feel so in order to
kind of alleviate that issue many of the
trees that I'm using around the
Riverside here are very small for one so
I can fit them in but also so that the
whole scene looks a little bit larger
than it really is especially since the
trees that I'll be placing toward the
back to actually make the forest are
gonna be quite a bit larger so in the
whole context of things I think it
should look pretty decent with having
these very small trees around the river
and
in the front alongside this rockwork
bridge that we have going over the river
and then putting the larger trees in the
back to actually make up the forest
itself to be honest this project for me
is also a little bit of a practice in
making foliage and I think some of the
things some of the ideas in here can
definitely be applied to theme parks
I've talked about nature already and how
it kind of relates to theme parks that
you're trying to create a scene that
looks like nature but you're arranging
it in a very man-made way to make it
look good and I think that very idea
definitely translates into theme parks
but also some of the ways of using the
planet coaster foliage like using the
smaller trees to give some detailing to
forests or ways of using small trees and
shrubs and sinking them into the ground
to create some low shrubs e-tailing I
think things like that will definitely
translate into any kind of theme park
foliage as well oh well I guess it
depends on what kind of theme park
you're going for if you're going for a
Six Flags park or something like that I
might want to just keep it more simple
Plus Western gardening is quite a bit
different so that's still something to
keep in mind with but through this
project I'm definitely forcing myself to
use the foliage in planet coaster in a
way different way than I normally would
and I think there's always something
that you can take away from trying
projects in a completely different style
that you've never tried before even if
you completely suck at it and if it
doesn't turn out the way that you like
it you still get to learn the pieces a
little bit more and you still get to get
a bit better by just going outside the
box so that ones that you're inside the
box that at least you can apply some of
the tricks that you've learned by trying
something else that you did as for me
for example I think I've gone a little
bit better through this project mixing
foliage and rock work when it's just
very minimal rock work just a few little
bits and bobs over here and adding some
small bushes and shrubs around that's
it's something which I always just kind
of did randomly but I think especially
through learning how to do it a bit more
organic in a Japanese garden think I can
get a little bit
and apply that in the future in some of
the other roads theme parks that I'll be
building plus making shrubs out of very
small shrubs and just clustering them
all together until you have a larger
shrub it's something which I never
really did to the extent that I've done
here but which works out quite well
especially on some of the shrubs that
I'm placing over here on this little
hill are fitting together quite well I
think
even though none of them are actually
real in-game items they're all sort of
mixes of smaller ones or cluster
together anyway
I think that's just about it for foliage
there's something which I wanted to
return to to talk about in this video
which is the name of this garden I know
I didn't talk about it that much in the
last episode but the name is a it's not
that great honestly
then again I'm also the person who came
up with Boneshaker and grapefruits I'm
not sure to what extent oh I ever get
out of that bad name habits but the
inspiration for this name came basically
from the word calico which stands for a
river spirits at least a small one like
karma means river and coal is something
that you add to the end of a word to
make it small so to speak so that's
where that came from
and then the N at the end is just four
ten which is the word for garden it's
not actually Cohen as in a park because
God that's one of those confusing things
if you have a long call as in coin
something would be a park whereas this
is just coin which is short coal and
there's not really much of a meaning
behind it it's just naming things
basically I chose the name because I
thought it sounded pretty awesome and
had no regard for what it would actually
sound like to an actual Japanese person
I honestly wouldn't be able to really
quite tell and I expected that no
Japanese people would actually reply and
find this but they did and I gotta say
I'm sorry for my for my pet naming it's
something that turns out works in every
language
just horrible at naming things in every
language anyway that basically more or
less kind of explains this garden
there's no particular meaning behind it
because there's no particular place
which is gone and would be located at I
didn't really come up with any
particular city or even Prefecture where
this would be it's just something which
I thought sounded pretty cool that's
said by the way and this is a little bit
of topic but still something that's been
on my mind recently and I just wanted to
drop in a video because it's something
that doesn't get a lot of attention but
recently has been picking up quite a bit
of momentum and it's just generally what
I'm talking about
is the Japanese planet coastal community
which as it turns out is much bigger
than I thought it was I thought it was
basically non-existence up until a few
weeks ago with just a few players
playing this game in Planet coves -
perhaps but recently we we've seen the
alien the right blowing up and if you
haven't seen this yet by the way you
have to see aliens - right it's such a
good dark ride and I'm sure if you
actually look for this on YouTube you
can find it it has many views but I'll
link it down in the description as well
but this is one of the things which made
me realize that there is quite a
Japanese language community behind
planet coaster as well and normally you
know I already know that the
international community for playing
coast is really big but the general
community speaks English as their main
language doesn't matter whether you're
from the Netherlands or UK or the US
there's a lot of crossover between all
of these local communities because they
speak English and they're sort of this
general English hub of planet coaster
contents where all the best stuff gets
shared and gets known by everybody but I
feel like because of the language
barrier because Japanese is really hard
to learn if you're not speaking it and
if you're not from Asia for instance
because it might be a bit bit easier if
you were from China but vice-versa it
goes as well barely anyone who is not
from Japan doesn't speak or speaks
Japanese since it's really hard to learn
these languages and so those really
barely any crossover between these two
communities even though there's some
really amazing stuff
from Japanese planet coaster players so
I'm not entirely sure where I'm going
with this discussion but um I've just
been sort of hoping the last few weeks
that it becomes easier to find some
crossover between these communities
since even though we might be completely
different languages and have trouble
connecting to each other I think it's
safe to say that really great planet
Costa community creations are pretty
Universal and creativity is pretty
universal which I guess gets shown off
by aliens the right as well by being so
popular across the world so I really
hope that there's gonna be a bit more
connection between these two and
hopefully I can figure out a bit more
what's going on in the Japanese
community because it's just really cool
to see that stuff it's also interesting
because they've seemingly developed a
little bit more apart since they don't
really communicate that much with each
other that there's slightly different
sort of styles and a slightly different
sort of atmosphere in both parts but
yeah I might dig into this a little bit
just because I think it's really
interesting but also because I think
there's bound to be a lot of really
amazing stuff which doesn't really get
to be known outside of Japan as much
because of that language barrier for
instance I logged into nico nico ants
actually check out aliens too right and
it turns out there are many videos even
recently of planet coaster with hundreds
of thousands of views back there which
is just really amazing never really knew
that it was this big I think actually
I've heard that the Merchandise creator
of planet coaster the frontier store now
has Korean and Japanese language options
I never actually found that out but it's
pretty cool if it does I think it's
really interesting I remember back in
well acoustic in three days there was
also a really really active Korean
community which had barely in any
interaction with the English community
but there were some really amazing
projects that came out of there but
you just had to search really hard to
find them because of that language
barrier anyway that's that's wildly
off-topic
maybe I'll relate this back someday when
maybe someday I'll be reviewing some of
this stuff or sharing it in any kind of
way plus they're they're bound to be way
better making Japanese scones than I am
just trying to add a bunch of this book
work go inside the river yeah let's get
back on topic so the last thing that
I'll be working on is creating this
little area between the bridges that I
made earlier and the bridge between the
valley it's not really too complicated
but it's a Riverside where I decided to
add a bit more rock work than in the
other areas and also keep this space a
little bit more open it's slightly
different in terms of foliage a little
bit more regular trees but that said I'm
not really experimenting yet with making
actual forest paths but I definitely
want to do so in the future it's just
that I've been like sort of struggling
trying to find out what I can best do
with the foliage in the game so for
instance some Japanese gardens will have
these paths that lead on the small trail
between these super tall bamboo forests
and I've tried this implant like I said
but it doesn't quite work out with the
foliage that I have so far so there's
just some things which I want to try in
terms of landscape but doesn't really
work out that well because it doesn't
work with the foliage in the game or the
foliage isn't really made for it or it
doesn't fit the foliage that I already
have in the park so it's a bit of a
struggle but at some point I do want to
move away a little bit from what I'm
doing right now and moving away from all
the open places all the many many cured
bushes and the Japanese pine trees and
actually move into some actual forest
trails because you'll definitely find in
some Japanese gardens some little paths
that just lead into a dense forest with
just trees all around and that's
something which I kind of want to get to
into in this garden as well you know
there are paths that you can actually
get lost in because everything so far is
pretty open
pretty easy to get around and I want to
start hiding some stuff as well that's
actually what I quite like about these
Conan's as well god I'm gonna go on a
nerd rant as well but yeah you can you
can walk into the garden feel like you
can see everything because it really
seems that way like when you walk into
God and everything is really open and
it's all presented to you in a very open
and place sort of way but we actually
get into it and when you walk down all
of the paths there are always these
places that you can't see initially
whereas you walk through it the trees
suddenly open and you're in this new
area that you'd never even expected
before and it's that sort of feeling
which I haven't really gotten into in
this garden yet everything is quite safe
and quite predictable but that's
something for the next episodes so far
just want to get the main stuff in and
the last thing that I'll be working on
in this episode is something which
should make this path not completely
useless I wanted to have something at
the end of this part going up the
mountains so we have a small observation
platform which isn't so much an
observation platform but just a place
where you can stand and take pictures or
maybe sit and just watch the landscape
it's really one of these designated sort
of photo posing places then I wanted to
adhere in there in the garden it's
inspired by this little place that I
found in korakuen garden which is close
to Tokyo Dome city in Tokyo where else
which also has this similar idea it
presents this little wooden platform
right on top of hill which looks out on
one of the main views of the garden and
I think it's just just those few use
that sometimes are exactly what you need
as you walk into garden and you're
always underneath the trees and you're
always walking alongside the foliage
it's sometimes really cool to just get
up to this hill and suddenly be above
everything and
have this huge view over everything else
so yeah that's something which I wanted
to have right there the platform itself
isn't really that good looking and I'm
also trying to hide it a little bit with
the foliage around it it's really just
about the view that you have from there
that's important now with that said
that's the end of this episode so thank
you guys for watching and I hope to see
you guys next time in which I'll be
working on the tea house at the side of
the lake bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you